hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today's video was more of going to be
very similar to the one we made about a
week or two ago
it's just going to be more of a
up-to-date kind of video of what's been
happening in the past two weeks what's
been you know what's going to be
releasing what's already released
stuff like that as i feel like we
haven't talked in a bit so i thought i
had to recap on what's been happening
within the game recently
so let's get started and there's going
to be three bits of info for today and
the very first one is that because today
is
august 20th warmonger is now officially
live for everyone so if you were not one
of the people that bought her for eight
dollars you can now purchase her for 15
000 steel within the in-game store if
you're unsure of who
warmonger is maybe need a refresher on
the weapons armory emotes and executions
just click the couple videos in the top
right as i covered everything you need
to know about her to justify your
purchase if you do need to
the other two bits of info for today is
that there is a new material releasing
within the game which is corroded green
this definitely looks a lot better on
heroes wearing armor personally not so
much with the clothing but i still think
it can work with people that have
clothing like viking
samurai and you know the lin but i think
it'll just be a little bit harder to
find the correct combination
whereas with most of the armors for the
knights just a simple slapping on with
some green color should definitely make
it pop out more
and then lastly there was a small teaser
of an upcoming title
update patch which will cover some
things within the newest core combat
update
we mentioned last video how this was
most likely going to be updated
a lot more frequently as this is going
to be making sure everything is up to
par and receiving updates more
frequently
this is one of those this patch will be
releasing on august 27th
for the quick tl dr of what the small
teaser of this post is saying
they're going to be changing some of the
feats that deal with nusha and warmonger
of course there's going to be full
details when they get closer to august
27th
but so far they are most likely looking
into more warmonger sweets as opposed to
new sha's but she's still a
consideration
as you know if you've been playing the
game for the past couple weeks
warmonger's feats are extremely insane
especially when it's a 1v4
even playing breach i've been queuing up
with two or three war mongers we've been
able to kill the commander
in about 30 seconds so it's pretty much
a cake walk when the full team is
stacked like that so there's definitely
going to be needing some changes for her
feats
on top of that zone attacks for the most
part were nerfed all across the board
although some of them got nerfed a bit
too much
so those ones that felt super super low
in terms of damage are now going to be
just a little bit higher
in terms of their damage not going to be
going back to their normal amount
but just a slight bit higher in terms of
their damage as they felt that it was a
bit
too low than they expected of course
there's no confirmation on what those
zone attacks are
we'll know a bit more next week also
going to be changing some things with
heavy attacks there's a whole load of
things going on with the heavy attacks
and then for deflect damage they're
going to be attempting to raise those
damage values up just a bit as there's
obviously a huge risk but a huge reward
for deflecting
the very final part has to do with
stamina costing in terms of light
attacks with regular light attacks
they're going to be nine as opposed to
12 and then the combo lights are going
to be six so
a slight reduction in the amount of
stamina that is costed to use the light
attacks which is good all across the
board making sure that we use more
attacks
more commonly and yeah that was pretty
much it like i stated this isn't going
to be the full patch
of course wait till next week and then
we'll be covering all these things again
and
plus the loads of new things that will
be coming in the title update
this is just a teaser for more of the
important things that they're going to
be focusing on so to give us an
idea of what to expect for next week's
patch yeah as always like to be if you
do enjoy guys subscribe if you're new i
cover the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
to hear updates the patriots and the
leaks if you want to be kept up to date
with everything happening within the
world of 400 and never miss out on an
update
definitely describe the channel and take
care guys have a great
day i'll see you all next week for the
title update peace out
[Music]
you